i'm a manager you know and like any man
and this is you know uh be a leader of
of the of the team
and
put the vision into action this is and
you know
and making sure that we are all aligned
and we are working as you know one
machine
that everybody you know pulls it and we
we all pull from our angle to the to the
same direction
so this is the first challenge
welcome to 20 minute leaders just sit
back relax and learn from the leaders of
today it's a journey each one is
different unique inspiring let's get
started
[Music]
this episode is powered by j ventures a
community driven vc fund in silicon
valley in partnership with lumitec
sponsored by homework ventures hippo
insurance oppos labs synergy global
hillel at stanford leap birthright excel
serona partners and in media partnership
with
c-tech welcome to another episode of 20
minute leaders today i have the amazing
timur herbal sidras with me the ceo of
lumitec
timur has recently joined lumi group is
lumitex ceo lumitec is the banking arm
for high-tech companies timor has over
20 years of experience in the high-tech
industry and held a variety of senior
management positions among the managing
partner at viola credit and chief
operating officer of eversea an israeli
fintech startup
at earlier part of her career tumor was
strategy and management consultant at
valoris consulting and worked with
europe's large telecom operators timor
also worked at intel's design center in
haifa in various projects leader and
project management roles in the mobile
processors division
timur holds a bsc laude in
industrial engineering from the teflon
and an mba from esade business school
to more or sadras ceo of lumitec thank
you so much for being here with me and
20 minute leaders how are you
i'm well thanks micah for inviting me
i've been waiting for this episode i've
been waiting for this episode for so
long and and we're going to have a great
time um timo your journey is fascinating
from
working as
product management
and product development team leader to
management consultant
to
being a general partner at viola credit
in the vc world and then being a chief
operating officer so as an as much of an
operator as you can get in the amazing
company ever see which was also on this
podcast
to now being the ceo of lumitec and
looking at the industry and the
ecosystem again from a bird's eye view
but now for more of a of an organization
that is here to support startups both
financially but also with with all
different types of programs and lumitec
is such a significant part of the of the
ecosystem not just here but also but
just in the world and so i'm really
honored that to have you here and to
learn a little bit about what you
experienced
timo how do you define yourself who are
you are you an operator a vc
a manager
well first i'm a very curious person
ah to begin with
so i'd like to know everything about
everything
although as an investor i usually say
that investors know everything and
nothing about everything
we have like an ocean of uh of day of uh
knowledge but this uh
dip
um
so i'm very curious
and i love the junction
and between technology business and
people
and i think that along my career i
always found a different implementation
for this junction
and
and i find it fascinating
and these days in the bank i i'm
learning like a whole new
world it's like
i landed in japan and now i'm i'm
studying to speak japanese
incredible did you think that you were
going to end up or not this is just the
you know middle of your career but did
you think that you would get to a point
where you're going to be an executive
within a bank or a financial
organization
well actually no
like at the beginning of my career i
worked or even you know what before my
career
when i was studying in the technion i
worked as a flight attendant in el al
which was a huge organization with union
etc etc and then i said you know never
again
i like the intimacy of a small
organization when everybody you know
can really make an impact
and but
when i faced the opportunity of coming
to lumitec
um
i i was
blown by and excited by the of you know
the magnitude and the power of the
platform
to come and you know make a real impact
in the israeli industry tech industry
and that's what's you know
that's what drove me in
so tomorrow what i really love to know
is if you can walk me through some of
the big milestones in your career
and
shine light on what you learned from
that experience perhaps or multiple
experiences to shape the way that you're
leading by example now because it's very
rare that i get to meet somebody who's
held executive positions at such a
variety of of amazing organizations in
such a variety of amazing positions
so maybe you can walk me through some of
these great milestones
okay so i'll start with my first manager
at intel back in the day that i was
still a student at a technion and i
worked in a student job
and then i graduated and they offered me
a new position as an engineer
managing you know something that was you
know i felt was really you know too big
for me
i was scared like hell
and
my manager insisted that i'm gonna take
it
and he told me you always want to wear a
suit that is two sizes bigger than you
so you have room to grow
and
actually it proved itself to be you know
as a very good advice
and it is an advice that i'm taking with
me along the way and also when i'm
talking to to young
people at the beginning of their careers
i always tell them the most important
thing in in choosing where you're going
to work is who's going to be your
manager and then
don't be afraid to take on chances
and
challenges so this this is the first
milestone
and so
if when you're looking more practically
about this idea of where a suit that is
two sizes bigger
you know if i'm looking at myself or
other you know young people on in the
beginning of their journey what is the
mentality that we should be in to embody
that spirit
well first you know
you know when i worked in intel you have
to wear your tag with intel values uh
at the back of the of the name tag
and for israel if they took off the
value that's saying risk-taking because
they say like us israelis are you know
we have it enough so i think this is a
lot about taking risk i think that
many in our uh industry are super
talented people
that throughout their you know life had
enjoyed a lot of successes
and sometimes super successful and
talented people are afraid to take the
leap of doing something that they don't
know and when you're gonna start to
start up a business or anything
you
you you're going against the flow you're
not going with the flow
so they're always going to be
more people that is are going to tell
you that it's not going to work that
people than people that are going to
support you and so i think this you know
courage of failing
you know you can do stuff and you can
fail and i i also tell my people and
roommate like we are making like 10 000
decisions a day we need to make sure
like we're going to make a lot of
mistakes we need to make sure that we
are
taking
more good decisions and bad decisions
and i think this approach is
is
the key
when you're talking about risk-taking
from a perspective you're holding that
perspective from from a few different
hats from
a general partner at viola credit
as a ceo of the eversi company
and now as the ceo of lumitec
are you bringing in the same mentality
for risk taking to those three
hugely different organizations does it
require the same persona or do you feel
like you needed to shift your thinking
as you've been transitioning from
different organizations
uh no i i think you know
it's
i must take a a step backward here
because i'm married to an entrepreneur
of a startup the real entrepreneur okay
and for him i am not a person that is
risk-taking okay so we need to put
everything into proportion still i was
working for a vc
and revenue stage company and the banks
okay but still i think that
when when you are um truthful to your
beliefs
and you listen to your like to your
intuition
that was you know a result of everything
that you gathered along the way
and you're not afraid of breaking walls
and doing what's right
and
i i think this is this this was the same
for me in every position that that i was
i was never afraid to speak up
my opinion
and
of course after thoughtful uh it was a
thoughtful opinion
and and i had the courage you know to
you know to push it through
uh you need to be smart about it because
you're always part of a team and
hopefully you are a part of a team that
includes people that are much smarter
than you in some areas
and then then you need you know to
choose your battles
but i think in that case the courage and
the risk taking was the same in each
in each position
the transition from viola credit
to a ceo chief operating officer
those really are
vastly different i'm sure from being on
the on the capital side to now being an
operator right we're often here that one
of the big gaps that we have between
financial institutions and startups is
the fact that oftentimes there's an
operator on one side and then a decision
maker on another side and sometimes they
don't they don't understand each other
well well you had the chance to
understand both what was that transition
like for you
well it was amazing
i spent 14 years in viola credit and
worked with you know hundreds of of
startups and very intimately with dozens
of startups
and i thought i know a lot about the
challenges but
looking at it from the other side
and when you need to push through
and
it taught me a lot you know many stuff
that i thought
um that were i realized that
were blind spots for me
when i was
on the investors side
uh
and i i now uh appreciate even more
uh the executives on startups
right
does the change now as you transition to
lumitec
you're because you're interacting with
both ends of the stick right both the vc
side of the ecosystem here and also the
entrepreneurial side
what what what do you take from your
time as an operator to your current
position as ceo of lumitec
so lumitec is a start that is a start
this is a startup in lumi
and
that's the spirit and not only mine but
that's the spirit of of everybody that
works for lumitec
and this is not very natural or wasn't
very natural years ago for a bank to uh
to understand how to um
correctly analyze the risk
in in startup companies
and you know my predecessor he fight and
she she was the entrepreneur and it took
you know the the early stage and i'm
coming in the revenue stage if i can
compare it to uh
to startups but we are still you know we
are
looking every day
how to be
first how to listen to our customers i
think this is the first role of a
successful startup anyway
and then how to be flexible how to be
agile how to
find the right solutions
and you know for the pains and the need
of our customers
so a startup within a bank lumi tech
what is that we hear we see banners
about it we see events about it you're
you're working with some amazing amazing
projects
what is lumita in essence
so
the idea behind behind blue medic is
that the tech
industry is different than any other
industry and it has different needs
and
if you if we want to serve those if we
want to be the financial home
and the trusted advisor
for for our clients then we need our
people to do only that
to breathe and live and tech and
startups and that's what we are doing so
our people yeah they are so they are
bankers
but they are part of the uh
they are they're part of the high-tech
ecosystem
so their training is all about
startups and tech and technologies and
trends in the tech
and how does a company build and what
are the stages and what are vcs and how
they are
built so this is the uh
this is the training that they are going
through and they are they see themselves
when we see themselves everyone each one
in our in lumitec
as a the partner
we're taking like we have
some percentage of our time is
is being uh
taking a job at our clients uh company
and watching their back
um
and and also being the ambassador of
those companies within the bank
and explaining where they're coming from
in order to ease all the processes you
know a bank has tons of regulation and
we need to make sure that we
you know
we adapt at the processes and
everything that we do into the real
reality of startups
right so
back to the startups perspective so if
we're looking at
entrepreneurs and in the ecosystem here
today
in what ways are they really interacting
with lumitec on on a day-to-day basis as
they're building their company
so you know at the beginning when we
have like two entrepreneurs with the
powerpoint deck
and uh so it's really helping them and
then you know it's the first
company they never built a company
before so it's really helping them along
the way with every step you know
watching that they don't fall in each
hall
you know first invoice coming from a
customer first investment coming from an
angel that god forbid is not israeli
sometimes so it's like tons of issues
that's to begin with and then later
to help them work on their financial
planning
and structure it right and give the
right advice on the right time and with
the financing because at the end of the
day that this is what we're doing you
know best we are the experts for credit
for uh for startups
so
at the beginning sometimes they need
like small financing
uh you know to to bridge timing uh
difference between an investment and
and their cash flow then later on they
need some kind of growth financing then
later on they need venture lending which
can replace some of the growth equity so
it's really working with them along the
way
and and giving you know are there our
professional advices
uh for financing correctly their growth
are they surprised and they were at this
interaction because
no i'm thinking you know traditionally
you know even five six years ago when
you're still thinking about you know a
bank and you're thinking about startups
you're thinking that the interaction is
not trivial and it's not intuitive yet
here you're saying that you're so inter
you're so integrated into the ecosystem
in such a meaningful way where they
might be consulting with you about
powerpoint slides or about some some of
their plans
that sounds like a very intimate
relationship that
is pretty new to this idea of a
financial institution working with
innovators in the ecosystem
but is this a true a smooth transition
for for all of us to make or are there
some blocks along the way
so first let me start by saying that you
know we are starter okay so we are still
we you know we have the vision we know
where we want to be but there is still
for us way to go
so uh but you see you see timor how you
even
i i'm bringing in this old mentality and
i'm calling you a bank and you're saying
no no michael you're wrong we're a
startup we're we're just like the
startups in israel we just happen to be
also with the bank and so we're seeing
both ends right
yes but what i mean is that we have the
vision we know what's important for our
customers okay
it's not perfect yet and you know we we
are still we have a lot of things to
improve and i actually i really
love the feedback that we are getting
from our customers to know where to
focus our
our efforts
and um
but yes there are uh i think you know
many especially growth-based startups
where this is our main strength
that
there is there is great intimacy uh
between
you know between their uh
relationship manager and the bank and
the cfo for example
really interesting
for you
as the ceo of lumitec
you're growing the team here
what is this like for you are your you
are your man you're seeing that you know
you're a startup with with a grand
vision and you're and you're looking for
eastern degree with the ecosystem what
are the biggest challenges that you're
that you need to be facing
on a micro or macro level to reach your
vision
well that's that's big well first
first
i'm a manager you know and like any man
and this is you know uh be a leader of
of the of the team
and
put the vision into action this is and
you know
and making sure that we are all aligned
and we are working as you know one
machine
that everybody you know pulls it
we all pull from our angle to the to the
same direction
so this is the first challenge
um there is also a challenge of um
uh communicating to the world which is i
think right what i'm doing now
that
that we are progressing you know every
every day every month you know we are
better and closer to our vision
and
and you know tell them you know come
try us see see how far we are going with
you in our support for your growth
i have the most important question
tomorrow one that uh truly i'm most
fascinated by
with everything you've done and your
background you can pretty much do
anything that you would choose to do
yet you choose this position
why
well
first well as as i told you i think this
is another challenge
of taking what i know uh
you know to do uh best and this is to
understand the real essence the real
risk
uh
in a startup and then translating
into you know smart financing into the
right
structure of of alone
and to really make the match between the
pain
and the
and the product
which is always you know what i'm
looking at when i'm looking at startups
so this is what i'm looking and you know
to find
myself
uh in london tech
timo toda
thank you very much this was wonderful
i learned a lot and i i came in knowing
that your journey is interesting and i
and i found it fascinating and and i
love the way that you're extracting
these different experiences and and
understanding both the complexities but
but also feeling that you're very very
optimistic about the integration of all
these different moving pieces
and i've been obviously following
lumitex activities for for a long time
now and then and i'm very very inspired
and i think that it's really a showcase
for the world to show how different
industries are are coming together
and decision makers are paving the way
for for for these meaningful connections
and
and uh i think that you know the
startups that get to work with lumitagar
are very very lucky so thank you very
much for joining me today and i really
appreciate it thanks michael really it
was fun
so thank you
[Music]